if you've got is not quite working
optimally then even though you might not
have any specific symptoms it can still
have an impact on your mental health and
your mental performance and inevitably
if it's not happy it's going to be
screaming at your brain all the time and
that is noisy and difficult for your
brain to cope with and that can lead to
things like brain fog and struggling
with focus and concentration for example
similarly if your gut isn't happy but
you don't really know from other
symptoms but you're getting loads of
bugs infections viruses all the time you
notice you're really susceptible that's
a good time to start looking at your gut
health there is a very strong line of
communication between your gut and your
brain which we refer to as the gut brain
axis and again they are chemically
connected through neurotransmitters that
are produced in the gut they are
hormonally connected by the HPA axis and
they are physically connected by the
vagus nerve and the chattiest organ
between your brain and your gut is your
gut your gut is constantly telling your
brain all sorts of different things and
throwing messages up that it's got to
deal with and people might think oh it's
your brain your guts not really doing
anything but actually your brain is busy
and it's communicating and it's a lot
through those microbes that live in your
colon